[Musik]
ich habe im jahre 67 als milizoffizier
als frischgebackener leutnant zu einer
freiwilligen massenimpfung gemeldet und
bin dann gleich am beginn dieser waffen
übung in den einsatzraum now das verlegt
worden
genau das hat zu der company gehört
wären stützpunkt in butzbach und zu
unserem aufgabenbereich hat gehört die
überwachung von drei grenzübergängen die
patronen waren sehr lange sein körper
intensiv sie haben drei vier und in
einem fall sogar acht bis neun stunden
gedauert
das heißt ungefähr die hälfte der
mannschaft hat jeden tag eine patrouille
durchgeführt und die andere hälfte hat
dann dafür gesorgt dass der nager
betrieb funktioniert nicht beeindruckt
eigentlich wie gut das ganze
funktioniert hat die einstellung der
soldaten zum dienst war für mich
überraschend gut
es hat kaum irgendwelche probleme
gegeben
und wenn es solche gegeben hat hat man
als zug stützpunkt kommandant das
eigentlich in eigenregie lösen können
und nach verantwortlich man hat führen
können
es gab keine einflussnahme seitens der
kompanie führung wir hatten auch keine
begleitpersonen
wir haben keinen keine zur wache dabei
gehabt keine keine schon da man diese
patronen alle in eigenregie durchgeführt
die einsatz form war vollkommen
ungewöhnlich wir hatten ja geübt angriff
verteidigung und ähnliches überwachung
einer grenze in dem sinne dass wir
praktisch eigene leute hindern sollten
in das anführungszeichen feindesland zu
gehen das war total neu